حوالي 20 شخصا اصدروا قرارا غير مسبوق في
تاريخ امريكا بتوجيههم لائحه اتهامات الى
ترامب ليصبح اول زعيم في تاريخ الولايات
المتحده يتهم بارتكاب جريمه هؤلاء الاشخاص
يشكلون ما يعرف بهيئه المحلفين فمن هي هذه
الهيئه وما هي صلاحياتها القضاء في
الولايات المتحده يعتمد على نظام هيئه
المحلفين بحيث لا يتم اتخاذ القرارات
القضائيه من دون استشاره هذه الهيئه
المكونه من مواطنين عاديين يتم اختيارهم
وفقا لشروط معينه ساشرح عنها لاحقا لعلمكم
هذه الهيئه لا تحدد ما اذا كان المتهم
مجرما ام بريئا ولكنها تحدد ما اذا كان
يجب توجيه تهمه رسميه لشخص ما بارتكاب
جريمه بالطبع بعد الاطلاع على الادله
وشهاده المدعين العامين ثم تقديمي قرارهم
للقاضي في القضيه هناك نوعان من هيئه
المحلفين الصغرى وتضم من سته اشخاص الى 12
شخصا وتكون علانيه لكن مداولاتها خاصه اذ
يتمتع المتهم بحق المثول امامها للشهاده
واستدعاء الشهود اما الهيئه الكبرى فهي
تختص بقضايا مهمه يرفعها عاده المدعي
العام في الولايه ويصل عدد اعضائها الى 23
شخصا ولا تكون مداولتها مفتوحه كما لا يحق
للمتهمين ومحاميهم المثول امام هذه الهيئه
وللعضويه في هيئات المحلفين يجب توافر بعض
الشروط اهمها ان يكون مواطنا امريكيا عمره
لا يقل عن 18 عاما ولا يوجد لديه اي عائق
نفسي او جسدي ولم يسبق ان حكم عليه في
قضيه